air raid alerts have sounded across
Ukraine again overnight Ukrainian forces
say 36 Russian cruise missiles were
intercepted across Ukraine including
over the major cities of Kiev khakive
and nipro Port facilities in Odessa were
also targeted the governor there says
one person was killed and Ukraine's
major port was damaged step Bassin has
worn out from the capital
49 missiles have been fired according to
the authorities here and 37 airstrikes
36 were intercepted but there were also
Hypersonic missiles used apparently on
an air base in the west of the country
we haven't heard about any damage or
possible casualties here but the
authorities say there is damage there
have been strikes getting through and
one of those strikes getting through was
in Odessa where the weather as here also
was very bad overnight there were
thunderstorms and the authorities the
governor of Odessa says that they have
used the Russians have used this bad
weather condition to fly very low and
hit the port once again of Odessa after
the grain deal failed and Russia pulled
out of it around 10 days ago this port
has been a Target many times because
this is where grain was transported from
through the Black Sea